HAVE BEEN AND THE EXTENT OF WHAT
THEY DO WOULD DEPEND ON THE
RESPONSE WE USE.
GRIFF: WE ARE JOINED NOW BY URI,
ADVISER TO UKRAINIAN DEFENSE
MINISTER.
URI THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME.
YOUR REACTION TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S COMMENTS THERE?
>> GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME.
OF COURSE, WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS SAID MAKES TOTAL SENSE.
WE AS UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN
LIVING WITH THE THREAT OF THE
USE OF TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPONS
OR CHEMICAL WEAPONS PRETTY MUCH
THROUGHOUT THIS WAR.
CONSIDER THAT THE RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA MACHINE IS OPENLY
VERY OFTEN CALLING ON THE
KREMLIN TO USE THESE TYPES OF
WEAPONS.
SO WHILE THIS RISK IS, OF
COURSE, VERY REAL WE STILL HOPE
THAT REGARDLESS OF DERANGED THE
RUSSIAN ARMY UNDERSTAND
CONSEQUENCES AND HAVE SEEN
RESPONSE ALREADY HAS BEEN DONE
BY THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
WITH RESPECT TO THE CONVENTIONAL
WAR AGGRESSION, SO THE RESPONSE
OF INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY TO
RUSSIA'S POSSIBLE USE OF
TACTICAL NUCLEAR USE OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS WILL BE MORE SEVERE AND
FRANKLY THIS WILL BE THE END OF
RUSSIA AS WE KNOW IT.
GRIFF: THE WORLD ADMIRES
UKRAINIAN FORCES FIGHTING
AGAINST A VERY LARGE RUSSIAN
ARMY AND THE SUCCESSES YOU'VE
HAD TWO COUNTEROFFENSIVES
REMARKABLE IN THE NORTHEAST
TAKING BACK THE TOWN OF IZIAM
AND THE COUNTER OFFENSIVE IN THE
SOUTH IN HARSON, TALK TO ME
ABOUT WHERE THE BATTLE STANDS
NOW.
>> THE UKRAINIAN ARMED FORCES
HAVE BEEN SPECTACULAR IN THE
LAST TEN DAYS BEGINNING OF
SEPTEMBER, LIBERATED
800 KILOMETERS AND THE TROUBLING
THING AND SOMETHING WHICH IS
VERY TRAGIC IS THAT WHAT WE ARE
DISCOVERING ON THOSE TERRITORIES
IS MORE ATROCITIES ANUAR CRIMES.
WE ARE DETERMINED TO CONTINUE
OUR COUNTEROFFENSIVE AND, OF
COURSE, THIS COUNTEROFFENSIVE
WAS MADE POSSIBLE IN PARTICULAR
THANKS TO THE MILITARY SUPPORT
THAT WE RECEIVED FROM OUR
PARTNERS AND IN PARTICULAR FROM
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT FOR STANDING WITH
UKRAINE IN THESE DIFFICULT TIMES
AND PROVIDING UKRAINE WITH THE
MILITARY SUPPORT, THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
GRIFF: YURIY SAK, THANK YOU, WE
HAVE RUN OUT OF TIME THIS HOUR,
THANK